Evaluate 3x squared
minus 8x plus 7
when x is equal to negative 2.
So to evaluate this expression
when x is equal to negative 2,
everywhere that we
see an x, we just
have to substitute
it with a negative 2.
So it would be 3 times,
instead of x squared,
it would be 3 times negative
2 squared minus 8 times--
instead of 8 times x, 8
times negative 2 plus 7.
And so what does this give us?
So we have 3 times
negative 2 squared.
Well, that's just positive 4.
A negative times a
negative is a positive.
Minus 8 times negative
2 is negative 16 plus 7.
So 3 times 4 is 12.
From that, you're
subtracting negative 16.
Subtracting negative
16 is the same thing
as adding positive 16.
So it's 12 plus 16 plus 7.
And so this is equal
to 12 plus 16 is 28.
And then if you add
7 to 28, you get 35.